As we go to our next game,
Dog Time. Dog Time.
Photobombs, like everything
in life, are always better
when they involve dogs. Always.
We found a delightful bunch
of dogs photobombing pictures
on DogTime.com.
For example, here's a classic.
Uh...
Got the dog
with the tat sleeves there.
He's probably driving a hybrid.
It's a Labradoodle.
Um, now, as wonderful
as that is, I have to admit,
I was a little disappointed
to learn that DogTime
wasn't just Time magazine
for dogs.
I mean, think of all
the hard-hitting dog news.
So, comedians, since I can make
you do whatever I want
on my program, I would like you
to list as many articles
as you can that might appear
in Time magazine for dogs.
Uh, examples might be
"This year's best tennis balls
rated for chewiness"
or "Why your farts
shouldn't startle you." Uh,
I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock. And begin.
-Jenny.
-"Are you a basic bitch?"
Points. Points.
Affion.
"How to bark all the time
like an asshole
when you live
in an apartment building."
Points. Jenny.
"Five things you should know
before you eat that chocolate."
All right, points.
Marlon Wayans.
"How to break up
with your owner."
Points. Affion.
"The top ten porches it would be
perfect for you to die under."
Points.
Jenny.
"Ten hot celebrity legs
perfect for humping."
Yes, points. Marlon.
"Squirrel-on-squirrel action."
Squirrels, squirrels, squirrels!
Points. Affion.
"Your owner--
really your best friend
or some asshole who lost money
on you in a dog fight?"
Points.
Jenny.
"How to bring that spark back
into the bedroom
when you've lost your balls."